so not too many people know this
but i was raised by goats
yeah this is different because i had
this position actually the last game
but i moved to d4 and then back to
[Music]
d6 are you serious
two games in a row
3.4 million people watched this video
but i guess not my last two opponents
two games in a row so i'll play rookie 7
idea queen h5 g6
to defend
oh thank you daniel newman chess
i don't know what that means but uh
maybe that means chess i don't even want
to guess
thanks for the ten dollars man wasn't
the race
i'm winning right yeah i have initiative
no no no no no no no no no yeah it was
back when like
uh i don't think iphones existed yet
so taken with like a real camera
i was trying to share the chess book
with the goats
let's go okay i saw that coming too wow
let's go oh what a game okay
let's go like i got him got him
oh more more money with this unusual
saying which i don't know what it means
but thank you
there's a funny line so takes takes
takes takes here and then double
checkmate
uh i make it work
i don't want to take all my time here
i'll just friend meat
man oh it's so beautiful
there we go the fork smothered meat
let's go or the pork because it's a pin
too the pork mate let's go
oh oh no ah this is what ludwig was
doing the other day
you just make you can make your head
like
um like a thing
yeah ah my face
i'm sorry eric rosen you cannot be in my
chat and go oh no my queen
g5 so i'm playing this for a win
no
nothing happened nothing happened
nothing happened
but this is the last photo i took before
i started running
um because it started just sprinting
after me
and it was so muscular
at least for a goose
um the other ones just didn't really
care like they saw i had no food
and they went about their ways but this
one
really wanted wanted something from me
um so i ran away thankfully i
not too many people actually know this
but i have legs so i was able to
i was able to run away and
and save myself
no i still made it no
i learned the slime i was very young
eight or nine years old
wait i still don't know what that means
i still have to kind of work my eyes
wow wow
i took all of white's things let's go oh
so i typed in oh this is cool i typed in
ducks
into
my google photos and look what came up
flamingos
yeah they have these at the the zoo
[Music]
they're like um they're kind of like
ducks but much longer
necks it's like a giraffe duck
but also kind of red or pink
uh is this better or worse
probably worse
i read some wedding travels alone and
doesn't have any number two to help him
do you like mushrooms
because after it takes takes the lights
restricted by this pawn
and if knight d5 i take take e6
and then after takes i take on g6 with
check
king f8 and i fork the king and the
queen
and if light moves let's say after e6
knight moves to b6
i take again if king f8
i fork so king d7
i take on g6 and d5 is weak
oh it's so colorful people say goat in
chat they're
referring to the acronym
yeah wait
but do we sacrifice the goat
for compensation
uh from
looks like nigeria like there's all
these nigerian princes
um that need help like
accessing funds and they're asking me to
send over
a few hundred thousand dollars
but
have to pick and choose my priorities
bishop take c2 wow
so bold
i might castle
wait i have 95 too
[Music]
95 hitting i'm so i'm threatening f7
with the triple fork
queen takes e5 check i was also thinking
one
so i was about like 13 years old maybe
13 or 14. i used to be really into
like soccer freestyle or football
freestyle
i should make another video like this
see what skills i've retained
oh vanguard vanguard's here what's up
vanguard
says i challenge you but you still ain't
calling
i left my cell my pager my home phone
at the bottom
uh
i don't know where my phone is right now
but there's there's larger priorities
let's take or no aposse is like a group
of people right
alexa what's a posse
alexa what's a posse
i'd rather not answer that oh
okay um let's look at this game
though you're night oh it's stalemate
oh wow i just saw white blunder than
knight
knight f1 was brilliant my f1 was also
losing because g5
g5 first and then takes
but good job i'm so proud okay that was
nice
hey the pawn cube survived it was
indestructible
for those saying is it's a square um
it's three-dimensional because it
survived through time
but i kind of understand why it's maybe
some people think it's a square
what does sheesh mean okay very quick
tennis
intermission so this is me against ray
robson
grand master in chess
wait for it wait for it hey it's a
tweeter
okay i should be able to do this no
[Music]
problem
yeah because we got the knight in
yeah this is this is gonna be simple
just have to get the move order oh no ah
i messed up
wait what did i do
oh the key moved this way which i wasn't
prepared for
okay
yeah what did i do waiting move don't
flag me
no oh no i messed up
no
yeah this is a fun line where white play
try to play extra safe but
still gets in trouble because of this
idea
um yeah we're having a hot tub stream
without the hot tub today
i don't own a hot tub
have to rent one or build one
how difficult is it to like build a hot
tub
you just basically need like a bowl and
hot water right
or like a large bowl alexa what does
chen's amends mean
winnie okola known professionally as
kenza is a canadian singer
record producer and music video director
from vancouver
no that's not what they said alexa quiet
let's go okay
any updates on the geese drama it was a
single goose
um as far as i know it stopped chasing
me
since i ran away which is uh
which is nice so
actually that may have been the last
time i took a walk
in the park i should return and see if
it's
maybe still there a little bit scared to
go back though
make a shocked face right now
it's hard to appear shocked when i'm
like not genuinely shocked
alexa shock me
it sounds like you're asking about shock
me want to hear something about it
yes according to wikipedia
shock me is a song by american hard rock
band kiss
which first appeared on their 1977 album
love gun
it was written by lead guitarist ace
fraley
freely
let's go okay wait what
was i hallucinating there
okay black was on the verge of flagging
and then all of sun black got like three
more seconds
some weird lag it's not fun to be chased
by
wild animals especially those that want
to destroy you
have you ever played squash i've eaten
squash
squash is like um it's a pumpkin like
vegetable
related to maybe a sweet potato too
but i don't recall like playing the
sports
a sport is far different from the food
uh
wait now i'm conflicted do i do it
you offered me ten gifted subs if i sat
my queen
i'm so conflicted does my opponent know
what's going on
i could take with bishop
i have to sack my queen don't stoop so
low
opponent wanted to take back
a point resigns oh
i i was having a moral dilemma i guess i
failed in all regards
or just going straight for the kill of
knight f5
um so i basically just concluded 93 is
the most most like useful multi-purpose
move
oh my god
this is stuff this position is black to
move oh no
look at this it's a nice little sandwich
it's like uh popper pumpernicker nickel
and uh
and white bread okay bye everyone